this is a production of Cornell
University
anyway I think everybody is aware of the
importance of the lakes to the
landscapes I think that most residents
are clear that what happens in the
watersheds is reflected in what goes on
on the lake and what I want to do today
is summarized about 40 years of my
experience with it we've got some
problems with units and I guess I better
try to get some of this straightened out
first volume of the lake is about ten
thousand million cubic meters if that
means anything to you it's kind of up
there with national debt and stuff like
that if a tornado is sucked all the
water out of the lake it would take 10
to 15 years for the lake to refill the
deepest parts about 400 feet so that
gives you an idea of what we're talking
about now we're going to talk about
we're looking about concentrations of
phosphate which instead of one with lots
of zeros now it's a lot of zeros and a
small number most of the times we talk
about a parts per billion or phosphate
that's five times ten to the minus six
grams per liter or it's about five times
ten to the minus three grams per cubic
feet meter but please note that most of
the nitrate is talked about in terms of
parts per million which a thousand times
more concentrated in phosphate one
example that will see later probably if
you put a cubic meter if you had it
pallet here with a cubic meter by the
way is about a cubic yard if you put
that in the lake and dissolve that you'd
increase the phosphate concentration by
about three to five parts per billion
that's just very chlorophyll
concentrations commonly
parts-per-billion micrograms per liter
and if you look at what goes on in the
early spring chlorophyll concentration
increases as eight parts per billion not
equal parts per billion a phosphate
carbon content of the algae sort of 50
to 100 times the chlorophyll content
okay one of the things that's important
to think about is biological activity in
Cayuga Lake depends on the
photosynthesis by the algae and that is
that energy from the photosynthesis is
an important source of energy for all of
the biological activity in the lake most
of the things we're talking about the
chlorophyll and the phosphate or
measured using standard universally
accepted methods all of the data is
online or in two very important honestly
seas at Cornell so well some of the
state is mine but an awful lot of it
isn't what I really want to do is look
this is the same inputs of streams
determines phosphate in the lake deep
lake which determines phosphate in the
thermos water in the summer or spring
and that determines the algal
proliferation in the summer and we
measure it by Cora Phil so we're going
you're going to see that a couple of
times five years ago I decided to
assemble the stream and lake data from
1972 through 2011 since 1972 I'd
collected about 2000 water samples about
2,000 Mike samples were available I had
a lot of professional interest after I
retired and I wanted to challenge my
brain and believe me this has been a
good challenge for my brain in 1962 for
a little history environmental quality
became a major concern at the University
agriculture kind of realized food
production agriculture and the
environment were all tied together and
they Bob young assembled a team of
professors sports Doc's grad students
research staff etc setter and I happened
to be one of those people and during
that period 1972 277 it was a very very
active group we produce several theses
Santa
publications a book a bulletin major
emphasis on the lake stream water
agricultural economics animal science
manure management guess what rural
sociology but the whole theme was to
integrate it we produced a book and
these are the project authors now
integration of everything was a major
purpose the group met for at least two
hours every second week for six years
and we had a lot of discussions and all
of everybody had to go if they got money
and Bob young watched he know he didn't
take take a sentence but he was really
really I just an incredible leader there
are two people here I want to talk about
one is Rao's we and of course my son but
Ray it was the lake person and we had to
start early on okay so how am I going to
analyze water samples and how is he
going to have analyzed lake samples so
it once the water gets in lake there's
not some big you know clear for
something like it we spent a lot of time
that we exchanged labs samples between
labs and so and so I want to really
point that out because later it's going
to become important the other person I
want to point out is Keith Porter helped
edit the book and all of that I Ed [ __ ]
yet is sitting back there head stand up
can you he was the guy that went out on
weekends and nights and whatever and
took water samples during storm so
anyway he said I'm glad to see him here
ok if we start with kind of the
conclusions from the 1977 thing the
levels of algae in the lake are
determined by the dissolved phosphorus
present the lake in the early spring and
the other important issue wants you
get enriched algae you can get rid of it
by just getting rid of the phosphorous
inputs real question is that consistent
with 1999 2 to 11 at all i want to do
just throw this up there don't pay much
attention to it you see a lot of it
cleared I just want to see okay here's
the phosphate in the spring chlorophyll
in the summer and yeah there's a lot of
noise but it's early clear a clear
relationship with to the question is how
did we get to phosphate in the spring so
let's start with Q lake in its
watersheds and this map defines the
source of the drainage and the lake
surface area is about ten percent of the
water said area now we adopt it as our
model watershed fall creek for several
reasons first of all it has a mix of
agricultural and forest land uses which
is fairly typical of the rest of the
watersheds so what we're going to do is
look at what happens with fall creek and
we're going to extrapolate that to the
rest of the watersheds via this idea the
other important issue we had usds flow
data from 1926 to the present this will
turn out to be extremely important
second thing I sampled about a hundred
feet above the usgs station I've walked
over the sampling site on my way to my
office in the morning if I took a sample
I just put it in my laboratory or did it
did the processing myself and that's all
close to my office and a watershed is
about twenty percent of the watershed
area now this is a just a brief map of
the watershed itself notice that there
to brant two main branches a freeville
it could trees on north from freeville
and then to the east it's Virgil Creek
we did their small villages and
population densities basically I think
it's reasonable to say that it's a
pretty good
representation of most of the water see
here's the bridge a forest our forest on
the foot of next to forest I'm sorry
pleasant go see okay but anyway what's
important is you see the pathway along
the edge of the bridge that's where I
took all the samples I stored by
sampling jewels in the superstructure of
the bridge here's where I here's where I
sampled from and notice it comes through
there and it's pretty well mixed here's
a nice winter scene a little very little
flow ice and snow or accumulated in the
watershed we get a thaw and oh all sorts
of funny things happen notice how dark
the water is there's a load of sediment
in it there's a lot of phosphorus in it
and it's very very important to take
these samples from steams like that
here's another one it's the summer storm
this is a picture of the USGS controls
stream and on a nice summer day oh
you're just some landscapes and notice
the agricultural land woods in the
background more agricultural land notice
it background buildings and diversity of
crops and more forests here's up just a
view across the valley and again
landscapes and woods here's a creek
above free vale notice the abundant
vegetation along the stream notice the
little stones flat stones that are there
these streams are pretty well stabilized
that notice now that there's a stream
and the background in the middle of this
slide but look at the buffering between
the stream and the agricultural Linus
Lake Como at the top of the creek here's
the fall creek before Lake Como again
notice the buffering
this is a virtual Creek and one of the
things i want to emphasize here don't
worry about the nitrate thing it's also
a source of phosphorus okay so let's get
to the data what I have here is a
summary from 72 2008 the log
concentration the log of load which is
slow times concentrations of C amount of
substance or to this case phosphorus
taken to a lake versus the flow and flow
is always a convenient way to to
summarize the deal what I want you to
notice so really is to look at the
difference in the color of the state of
sample points the black ones are 70 to
75 the red is 2006 the green is two
thousand two thousand eight nine what I
want to conclude from this is the
loading has not changed appreciably in
the period 1972 to 2009 now
statistically I presume you might think
of a model that would enable you to do a
good statistical test my attitude is hey
you know I'm not going to go there but I
look at these so make up your mind if
you say oh forget about it I don't
believe it but anyway we'll see this
later so how do you do it well the one
thing I do want to point out the period
notice the variability in loads vs 1
given flow and you think oh my goodness
that's a sloppy laboratory work that is
not sloppy laboratory work we've done a
lot of samples in which you take
consecutive samples within a few minutes
of each other and taken to the
laboratory and there's very little
variation if you wait a few hours and
take another sample you get into that
variability that you see there so how do
we deal with that variability the first
way is look at load versus flow and
usually you can do some math
mix of that and you can either use a log
or a linear scale the big deal is take
lots of samples samples all seasons and
years sample storms low flow and
everything else because it takes that
many samples to really get what you need
to know now I did a here's another way
to look at the data this is a
concentration now it's not the quantity
it's the concentration per unit volume
and instead of doing with the flow I've
done it with flow ranges and these
different boxes are 0 to 50 CPS 50 to 99
etc all the way up to 1500 to 2000 cubic
feet per second and the last one is over
3000 TV I don't you probably looked at
box plots before I pull one one little
thing out and pulled it over to the left
and that bottom of that box is at the
concentration that includes everything
below that concentration or that's the
twenty-five percent of the samples are
below that concentration if you go to
the median fifty percent of course the
top of the box of 75 percent and the
twister is ninety percent so this is a
convenient way to summarize and what I
finally did was just do a regression of
average on average of the different so
this is our equation that converts load
in cubic feet per second to
concentration of soluble phosphorus in
terms of per unit one
you'll see this later well okay now
we've defined the load and the
concentration for Fall Creek 1972 to
2008 next we extrapolate to all the
watersheds first approximation one thing
that's pretty well documented flow per
unit of drainage area is the same for
all watersheds area fall creeks twenty
percent of the total area of the lake
wit like shed so five times fall creek
is equal to input into what is all the
watersheds well you might expect the
next proxim a shin ok we're going to
also extrapolate the load from Fall
Creek to the whole watershed well we've
devoted develop now the loading from
watersheds now we turn our attention to
how to relate this to phosphate in the
lake and our go production now there's
two things about the lake that are
pretty important to understand the first
one is and I think don't think there's
any controversy about this fall and
winter the lake cools reaches four
degrees it's mixed thoroughly by March
the dissolved constituents of the lake
are equal north to south east to west
top to bottom etc etc now during the
summer things are a little different
because the surface water warms up and
water floats on top and that's where the
solar radiation is and the algal begin
to grow and they proliferate primarily
in the surface layer so now we conclude
that the phosphate in the deep cold
water in the lake is an integrated
average of stream inputs over months and
years and recall is lake deeper than 60
meters does not mix during the summer
with the warm surface but it does in the
wintertime so now the deep water changes
slowly over years and it turns out we
have a really really good set of data on
the deep water in the lake first of all
the research in the 68 to 70 for x ray
Ogilvie and John Barlow sample the lake
all the depths all a year since then the
lakes or schooling people have taken
samples of the intake for the lakes or
schooling which is deep water 60 Plus
meters so those two things we know what
the concentration in the lake water has
been or something wait a minute there's
a missing slider is it oh here is the
graph on the left is the concentration
in the deep water and the x-axis is year
notice in the upper left-hand sutter
there's the 68 to 70 for data and then
beginning 25 years later in 1999 the
concentration is dropped to somewhere on
for 23 24 25 and then it gradually
increases as we know from there so why
this large difference between 74 and 99
it's about eight if you compare 99 and
210 and it's if you go later it's about
six parts per million so why well we go
back to we go back to our 1972 277 data
and if you you don't recall probably the
phosphate and detergent was banned
in 1973 so we had spent we spent a lot
of time in our deliberations from 70 to
the 77 on the impact of this on the
phosphate in the lake and it turns out
that detergent p this the phosphate in
the detergent was a very large fraction
of the total phosphate going into the
lake from Seward population as a matter
of fact the two together about a half a
kilogram per capita per year now by 2005
a hundred percent of the detergent p has
disappeared on top of that the lake at
Cornell are they fire you think a sewage
treatment plant has removed on the order
probably a little more than half of the
excreted be so this is a if you look at
just the Seward population which of
course that the output from the sewer
plant was going directly into lake it
was about forty four thousand kilos per
year for the whole late for the 40,000
done sword about eleven thousand kilos p
per year and the total is about 55 now
obviously these are kind of broad
generalizations but if you look at that
ten thousand million cubic meters of
lake water that's equivalent to about
five to six parts per billion decrease
in what you would expect to find in the
lake and i think it's a it's well rocky
i can document all of this if you want
to find out about it you can read the
book anyway now we're back to looking at
this difference between 99 in 2011 which
is documented by the lakes or schooling
and notice it does go from somewhere
around 52 somewhere around 10 in that
period of time and so the question is
what happened well again we're back to
the lake it's very large annual puts the
watersheds varies between ten to fifteen
percent of the lake volume so now if
you're changing the amount of phosphate
going into the lake in a given year
you're not going to see that right away
you have to wait and least five years
six years two years whatever what is it
how can you how can you do that well i
puzzled over that for a while one of the
really key issues is in 1972 the
chloride in the lake and increased to
about 100 parts per billion and steve f
learned his group notice that that had
started the chloride started go down
once they quit putting that the fines in
the blake from the excess of of mining
it's 100 parts per million 1970 by 1976
has gone down to about 60 parts per
million and you can see that's kind of a
gradual decrease approaching probably
the current chloride steady state in
lake around 55 parts for bait so that
tells us right off hand oh okay that
lakes big and core i just said we've got
problems so okay if things get now we
start looking at stream flow and this
graph is 1963 2010 the green things are
yearly loading or this is full yearly
flow data notice the black line which is
five-year rolling average and how that
goes through episodes of high and low
flow so now we say oh wait a minute how
are we going to air
Bridge this over years if we sort of say
hey there now the flow determines the
amount delivered to the late okay so
here's the here's the approach we first
of all on the far left graph we've seen
that before that's core ID in the lake
as it decreases over time the second
graph is the delivery of water that flow
into the lake five year I'll reduce the
next one is the concentration versus
flow we're going to combine those two
middle ones and then we have to see if
what we can do to get that to finally
see how that impacts the phosphate in
the deep lake so we've got all that
together and so how many years now now
here's where things get a little messy
maybe so look I know what the flow is
for this history the concentration box
plot tells me how that concentration is
distributed as we go through flow
regimes there are 750 samples in that
box plot now we're going to say oh we've
got that that's good data so now we
start our matrix the first column we
list the let me go back I think maybe a
little clearer for starting the first
column in right now I think not it's
hard to get this all tied together the
first column we list the concentration
of the beach leak lake that's for each
year nineteen ninety nine to two
thousand eleven the next column is the
amount of flow or the load the preceding
year the second column is the average
load over the two preceding years third
column is three years etc it's set on to
ten years
so we got that so now here's a just sort
of a piece of matrix got a year late be
a first-year taken 30 out to 10 etc okay
now we take we look at that we put this
into a correlation coefficient matrix ah
I think you've got a little this little
of small but let's say so these are the
correlation for the second column n is
the correlation coefficient between the
phosphate and the lake and the stream
average input for the first year second
year third year fourth year etc and if
you look at the correlation coefficients
first one year forget about it second
year it's a little better third years
better still finally you get to six
years you get a correlation coefficient
a point eight nine my interpretation is
all that's the key issue is summarized
stream flow or stream inputs over six
years and that should be correlated well
it is correlated obviously with the
phosphate in the deep lake and I want to
call you attention to the right-hand
column which indicates the number of
days in that average now remember the
concentration the the box plot was
concentration for flow regimes for a
flow
great essentially well we've used the
USGS data we know what the flow is every
day for how many years you want in there
and it's about two thousand days go into
that six-year average so if we've done a
good job of getting an unbiased sample
of flow regimes based on our 750 samples
all we're doing is just taking samples
of that out and applying it to two
thousand days so I think this is this is
this is a free unbox this is pretty
unbiased the whole problem may be biased
estimate of how to do it but in terms of
the voting phosphate from the stream I
think that's a pretty unbiased estimate
so we've okay we've got to stream inputs
averaged over the previous six years is
about the best concentration of deep
water in the lake so now there are about
four variables that we pick is really
important and this is correlation matrix
two thousand two thousand eleven ten
degrees of freedom ok the first the
six-year business that's the six-year
input from the stream the eff is the
deep water measured in the effluent from
the lakes or schooling system the lake
milk okay APR is the measured phosphate
in the lake in April which is part of
the lakes or schooling data all the
coral CHL is chloride for the whole like
chlorophyll for the whole lake well they
call it one percent probability
correlation coefficients point six eight
obviously the chlorophyll and the other
things is sort of okay particularly you
want to call your attention to the
six-year correlation with the effluent
that's the measure deep concentration
lily has lake phosphate in April it's
not the best all chloride in the summers
not bad and anyway I think those are
reasonable correlation coefficients
considering this is kind of 40 years of
experience from lots of different
sources of samples etc etc so we pretty
well is here's my summary of the
relationships we started out and i think
that the correlation coefficients pretty
well say well yep that's not too bad i
just summer here says SRP in the lake in
the summer vs that's the phosphorus in
the lake in the summer versus secure
average from stream inputs summer
chlorophyll six year averages stream
inputs there's obviously a lot of things
to be done there here's this four of
those things kind of put together
alright let's get down to the general
summary okay so what have we learned the
phosphate concentrations varied from
four to 15 micrograms per liter 1974 to
2011 concentration of phosphate in the
spring is correlated with the six year
average of phosphate input from the
streams corphals increased and decreased
in phase with the variation in phosphate
but there's a lot of variation that's
not explained by the phosphate this is a
multi variable problem most likely
things to look at more carefully is
temperature solar radiation
wind etc etc well I looked at that a
little bit and I decided it was beyond
my ability deal with it I didn't have
the data I thought anyway the second
went chlorophyll Conservation has varied
from four to ten micrograms per liter
and within the period 68 2 2011 and I
would argue that we have covered a lot
of history of the lake if we want to
look for the guide to the future I would
say you could look at the chlorophyll
concentration but since you go to other
things you can look at the deep lake or
six years or whatever there's a lot of
variability but that's going to happen
one of the things that I think is very
very important a lot of people i think
at least mike scuttlebutt is they look
at the lake and says oh it looks
terrible it must be all that phosphorus
that went in and it's all at kora Phil
that's really far far from the truth the
reality is there are a lot of suspended
solids that are consequence of all set
on all the settlement that's gone in
with all the storms and that's all mixed
up with chlorophyll and if you really
look for Phil in a very clean lake this
the lakes very clear and it looks clean
etc etc so I think a lot of
misinformation and whatever about the
way that the lake looks is not
necessarily just chlorophyll it's partly
chlorophyll but very often if you looked
I don't have look today but last for
three days you see a lot of stuff in the
lake right that's sediment from storms
it's spring chlorophylls almost zero and
during summer concentration varies
widely believe me it's not sloppy lab
stuff they're real variations in
chloride a chlorophyll during the summer
the other thing I think is very very
important the phosphate dissolved in the
water has no important influence on the
macrophytes that is the so-called weeds
those big things they're usually
restricted to the shallow water less
than six to eight meters in depth so a
lot of people sort of thing oh that must
be phosphorus in the lake water that's
influenced in a proliferation those
micro fights well some maybe but mostly
they get their phosphate from the
sediment so if you want to predict you
to chlorophyll and algae growth you can
look at the phosphate in the lake source
cooling water and I presume Cornell will
continue to sample that water and we've
seen from past history what that deep
water concentration of phosphate will do
in terms of Korra fill in the lake so
you don't have to do all this stream
sampling just rely on cornell to keep
monitoring the phosphate in the effluent
from course schooling if you don't like
Cornell Zeta John half minute Hobart
William Smith has collected and
published several years of data in far
more detail than the lakes or schooling
data so if he continues his work we need
not duplicated with the future
consultants & Dec are well developed
lake and watershed models by 217 so they
say there will be a TMDL
total maximum daily load model I am an
opinion and currently the quality of the
lake is very good to excellent but the
great challenge is invested invasive
species do we know how to manage them oh
very good thank you a question this has
been a production of Cornell University
on the web at cornell edu